first off congratulations because I
absolutely loved the movie I am living
in my parents house right now so I felt
like it was very appropriate for me I
wanted to start with the process of
putting this script together because
Jedi know when it came to something like
trainwreck you really pushed a me to
make that script more personal so I was
wondering if this was a similar
situation where there's permutations of
this script that are closer to Pete's
real life and also ones that were
further away I think you know we were
always aware that we wanted this to be
fictional but lead to some sort of
emotional truth so you know in real life
you know Pete wasn't a slacker pothead
in his 20s who had no direction he was
actually a very driven comedian who was
on Saturday Night Live at 20 years old
he actually succeeded crazy early in a
lot of ways the opposite of this but
this was a bit of an imagining of what
might have happened to him if he didn't
find comedy and we bought in a story
like that we could show you how he was
feeling and what it took for him to get
over you know the the grief and trauma
that his family went through and Pete I
was reading in the the press notes that
there was a script that you wrote with
Dave a while back that didn't pan out
before you guys wrote this one so I'm
just curious now what was that about and
how did you get over that not working
out but then jumping to this I think it
was just about it was like 90 pages of
just like fart jokes like it wasn't
there was no like humanity in it there
was no like emotion there was no yeah
there wasn't any of that and then you
know once we started working with Judd
you know how he's so great at you know
doing all those things he really created
a great product of emotion and we did
into this beautiful story that we we
have now I couldn't agree more
Jed I did want to ask you a little bit
about the runtime on the movie and your
movies in general because you are well
known for having a very full comedy and
drama
on your resume so have you ever run into
a situation where I don't know some sort
of executive might have said to you this
movie isn't too this movie is too long
especially because this was on the South
by Southwest lineup and it is kind of a
you know a trope for festivals that it's
more programmable if your movie shorter
oh for me there's usually a moment where
I realize that if I make it short I'm
going to lose some of the character work
or the story in a way that's gonna make
it worse and so you're always debating
what is the attention span of the
audience and I'm usually of the mind if
you care and you're enjoying the world
you don't mind staying for another 10 or
15 minutes if it's gonna deepen the
whole thing and the annoying part of me
is always like well if you're gonna
watch six hours of tiger King in a row
you could handle to 15 come on you know
we're not hurting Tigers I genuinely
mean it you earn every minute of screen
time in this movie I think this is a
story that definitely calls for it
Pete now that you have a great writing
credit to your name how about getting
behind the lens and directing is that of
interest at all oh absolutely I mean if
I'm ever lucky enough to be able to do
that that would be great I think you
know just watching Judd is incredible
you know you get to watch I've said this
in a few interviews it's like watching
Willy Wonka make his candy it's just
watching a genius at the helm and if I'm
ever fortunate enough to be able to do
that that would be wonderful
well Judds able to churn out movies like
this because he had good folks leading
the way for him and this leads me to my
last question a little off topic for you
Judd I was just wondering if you've ever
considered directing a narrative
scripted film about Garry Shandling's
life I haven't you know I felt so lucky
to find so much material about Garry
video diaries jokes and in a lot of ways
that project is end diaries of Garry
Shandling the doctor
mentoree felt like the story he wanted
to tell it felt very guided by Gary I
think there are a lot of ideas he didn't
find a way to express and in his work
that he was just dancing around and I do
think that you know that was the way to
do it and then we did put out a book
called it scary Shandling's book last
year which has a lot more of his diaries
and jokes and it's an oral history so if
people are so hungry for info and I
always am that's a great book I'll
always want more but I respect that
approach I have a feeling you've
probably been asked this but Judd are
you gonna let a Pete give you a tattoo
anytime soon
there is a part of me that wants to you
know I would have to get a lot of
electrolysis to clear an area I got a
clear brush and then and then I can do
it so it's all about location location
location
never thought electrolysis was gonna
come up in one of my interviews but I
thank you guys so much and again big
congratulations on the movie thank you
very much